Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Citoyens, bienvenue au Rest is History, avec moi Dominique Sandbrook et mon ami Tom Holland. Ou, comme on dit en Egypte, Ahlan marawapan mikom fil albaki ho altarik, mei Dominique Sandbrook, wasadiki, Tom Holland. That's right. Our subject today is the French invasion of Egypt at the end of the 18th century. Napoleon, the Rosetta Stone, the Battle of the Pyramids, the Battle of the Nile, Tom Holland.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家播客番外、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。公民们，欢迎来到《历史的余烬》，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominique Sandbrook），我的朋友汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）也在。或者，正如我们在埃及所说：Ahlan marawapan mikom fil albaki ho altarik, mei Dominique Sandbrook, wasadiki, Tom Holland。没错。我们今天的主题是18世纪末法国远征埃及。拿破仑、罗塞塔石碑、金字塔战役、尼罗河战役，汤姆·霍兰。
This is the best subject we've done since Alexander the Great, isn't it? I'm still reeling from your impersonation. Multilingual. Tom Holland, this is the best subject we've done since Alexander the Great, isn't it? I'm still reeling from your impersonation. Multilingual. Yeah. Multilingual. I mean, I've had so much grief for my, frankly, brilliant impression of Liam Neeson. Yeah. And you've gone on quite rightly.
这是我们自亚历山大大帝以来做过的最好的主题，对吧？我还在回味你的模仿。多语种。汤姆·霍兰，这是我们自亚历山大大帝以来做过的最好的主题，对吧？我还在回味你的模仿。多语种。是的。多语种。我的意思是，因为我坦率地说非常精彩的连姆·尼森（Liam Neeson）模仿秀，我招致了太多的抱怨。是的。而你则继续进行，这很对。
That was shocking. You've got two different... You've got... What? That's... I am very much... I'm not parochial. I'm not introverted.
太令人震惊了。你有两种不同的……你有……什么？那是……我非常……我不是狭隘的人。我不是内向的人。
I'm talking to our international audience, to our French and Arabic listeners, and just giving them a little nod that we're not all, you know, Wiltshire and Stonehenge. That some of us are very outward-looking, citizens of the world. That's definitely how I see myself.
我在对我们的国际听众、我们的法国和阿拉伯听众说话，只是向他们稍稍致意，表明我们并非全都是威特郡和巨石阵。我们当中有些人眼光非常开阔，是世界公民。这绝对是我对自己的看法。
Like Napoleon. And how I think I'm seen. Yes. Okay, so today's episode is on one of the most brilliant episodes not just in the napoleonic wars but i mean it's one of the great stories of history how napoleon i mean he he invades egypt a 2 000 mile trip across the mediter, dodging the Royal Navy and so on. And it's brilliant both in itself, but also because it opens the floodgates for study of Egyptology. And in a way, it's the kind of primal start, isn't it, for the relationship of Islam with the modern West. So, Tom, let's take up the story um we are in the late 1790s napoleon is not yet 30 i mean that's one of the extraordinary things it's a bit like
就像拿破仑。也是我认为自己被看待的方式。是的。好吧，今天的节目讲的是拿破仑战争中最精彩的篇章之一，我的意思是，这是历史上最伟大的故事之一，拿破仑——我的意思是，他侵略了埃及，横跨地中海进行了2000英里的航行，躲避皇家海军等等。它本身就很精彩，而且它还为埃及学研究打开了闸门。从某种程度上说，这是伊斯兰教与现代西方关系的一种原始起点，对吧？所以，汤姆，让我们接着讲这个故事，呃，我们身处1790年代末，拿破仑还不到30岁——我的意思是，这是最不寻常的事情之一，这有点像
it's a bit like alexander isn't it that's what i mean so much about this story is actually a self-conscious absolutely reenactment of alexander's conquest of egypt so napoleon you know he's from corsica he has distinguished himself kind of with his whiff of grapeshot in the service of the Directory, who are running France after the sort of the backlash against Robespierre. And before the whiff of grapeshot, he has saved Toulon, which is the kind of major French naval base on the South Mediterranean coast. That's right.
这有点像亚历山大，对吧？这就是我的意思，这个故事的很大一部分实际上是有意识地、绝对地重演亚历山大对埃及的征服。所以拿破仑，你知道，他来自科西嘉，他曾以“葡萄弹的微风”（whish of grapeshot）为督政府效力而崭露头角，督政府是在对罗伯斯庇尔的反弹之后统治法国的政权。而在“葡萄弹的微风”之前，他拯救了土伦，这是地中海南部海岸主要的法国海军基地。没错。
And he saved it from a kind of a royalist british takeover uh he's seen that off um a character called sydney smith uh as in the process of evacuation has blown up part of the arsenal so he's a figure who will reappear but this is one napoleon so much kudos that he basically he he ends up being given command of the revolutionary army that then invades Italy. Exactly. That's where he really makes his name, isn't it? With the Army of Italy. So this is the late 1790s.
他把它从保王党英国人的占领中拯救了出来，呃，他击退了这一企图，呃，一个名叫西德尼·史密斯（Sydney Smith）的角色在撤离过程中炸毁了部分军火库，所以他是一个会再次出现的人物，但这就是拿破仑，这给他带来了如此多的声誉，以至于他基本上——他最终被任命为随后入侵意大利的革命军司令。没错。这正是他真正成名的地方，对吧？率领意大利军团。所以这是1790年代末。
He wins battle after battle. That's David's painting, isn't it? Of him looking, dashing and rowing on a horse, crossing the Alps. Exactly. So after a very rough time for France, suddenly they found this dashing, swashbuckling hero whose Frenchness actually is slightly ambiguous because of course he's from corsica but napoleon gives them something they haven't really had during the days of the kind of endless sort of revolution eating itself madame guillotine stuff which is a genuinely
他赢得了一场又一场的战役。那是大卫的画，对吧？画中他看起来英姿飒爽，骑着马跨越阿尔卑斯山。没错。所以，在经历了法国非常艰难的一段时期后，他们突然发现了这个潇洒、风流倜傥的英雄，他的法国人身份其实有点含糊，因为他当然来自科西嘉，但拿破仑给了他们一些在无休止的革命吞噬自身、断头台横行的日子里从未真正拥有过的东西——一个真正
dashing handsome swashbuckling youthful hero and that's what david puts in his paintings and napoleon gets all this loot i mean napoleon is incredibly corrupt right from the beginning he basically amasses tons of loot so he's suddenly very rich he's very famous he's a celebrity and the directorie love him the director is there but they're well they do you're right because they're starting to get worried aren't they quite keen to get rid of him because they can can sense that this is a man in a hurry and on the make. So their first scheme for him is Britain. Yes.
潇洒、英俊、风流倜傥、年轻的英雄，这就是大卫画进他画作里的形象，而拿破仑获得了所有这些战利品——我的意思是，拿破仑从一开始就极其腐败，他基本上搜刮了大量的战利品，所以他突然变得非常有钱，非常有名，成了一个名人，督政府非常喜欢他。督政府存在着，但他们——好吧，你们是对的，因为他们开始感到担心了，不是吗？他们很渴望摆脱他，因为他们能感觉到这是一个行色匆匆、唯利是图的人。所以他们为他制定的第一个计划是针对英国。是的。
They talk about invading Britain, don't they? Talleyrand, who is the foreign minister. He and Napoleon are very keen on this idea of invading Britain. Basically, Napoleon says, eventually, no go. You know, it's going to be much too tricky. But it's one of these great invasion scares in britain at the end of the 1790s so they go for the obvious alternative so why cross you know 20 miles of the channel when you can cross 2 000 miles and go to egypt and so well there's an anti-british yeah it absolutely is and so in a way, this is fighting, this is taking the war to Britain because Egypt has become strategically key
他们谈论过入侵英国，对吧？外交大臣塔列朗（Talleyrand）。他和拿破仑对入侵英国这个主意非常热衷。基本上，拿破仑说，最终，行不通。你知道，这将会非常棘手。但这可以说是1790年代末英国面临的伟大入侵恐慌之一，所以他们选择了显而易见的替代方案——既然你可以横渡2000英里去埃及，为什么还要去横渡20英里的海峡呢？所以，这是一个反英的——是的，绝对是。所以从某种程度上说，这是一场战斗，这是把战争带给英国，因为埃及已经变得具有战略关键性
because of the British, the emergent British empire in India. And this is what's grumbling on in India at the moment is actually Arthur Wellesley fighting, so the future Duke of Wellington, fighting Tipu Sultan in Mysore. And it's becoming clear that, well, I mean, basically, it's been clear ever since the Seven Years' War, when France was roundly defeated, lost its
因为英国人，即新兴的英国在印度的帝国。此时此刻在印度正酝酿着亚瑟·韦尔斯利（Arthur Wellesley，即后来的威灵顿公爵）与迈索尔的蒂普苏丹（Tipu Sultan）的战斗。而且情况变得越来越明朗——好吧，基本上，自从七年战争法国遭到惨败、失去了
holdings in Canada, lost its holdings in India, that Britain now has a kind of global grip that the French are obviously slightly envious of. And so Egypt becomes the target, both because it will frustrate British links with India, but also, I think, because the French see North Africa as kind of their backyard. They do. They've sort of been thinking about expanding into the Mediterranean. We talked before in a couple of our podcasts about how during the French Revolution and the sort of late period Enlight know, the late period Enlightenment, there is this extraordinary romance of Greece and Rome and this fascination with the classical world
它在加拿大的领地、失去了它在印度的领地以来，情况就很明朗了：英国现在拥有了一种法国人显然有点嫉妒的全球控制权。所以埃及成了目标，不仅因为它会阻挠英国与印度的联系，而且我还认为，是因为法国人将北非视为他们的后院。他们确实是这么想的。他们一直在考虑向地中海扩张。我们在之前的几期播客中讨论过，在法国大革命和晚期启蒙运动时期，
and classical antecedents. And Napoleon has already been pictured as a kind of Roman figure, hasn't he? I mean, crossing the Alps is quite kind of Hannibal-like behaviour. And clearly, right from the start, the idea of invasion, as soon as the idea of an invasion of Egypt is mooted,
人们对希腊和罗马有着非同寻常的浪漫情怀，并且对古典世界和古典先例有着这种迷恋。拿破仑已经被描绘成一种罗马式的人物，不是吗？我的意思是，翻越阿尔卑斯山的行为很有点汉尼拔的做派。而且很显然，从一开始，入侵的想法——一旦提出入侵埃及的想法，
people are thinking, oh, just like Alexander the Great, and this is going back to the Romans, and that's in their minds. Telly Ron, who is such a kind of Peter Mandelson cube, I mean, kind of brilliantly subtle, clever, manipulativeulative survivor constantly being knocked down constantly coming back he'd been royalist he becomes a republican he ends up a royalist again
人们就会想，哦，就像亚历山大一样，这可以追溯到罗马人，这种想法就在他们的脑海中。塔列朗，他就像皮特·曼德尔森（Peter Mandelson）那样，我的意思是，有一种精妙绝伦的微妙、聪明、善于操纵的求生本领，不断被打倒，又不断卷土重来。他曾效忠保王党，后来成为共和派，最后又成了保王党。
i mean it's kind of astonishing record but he said he said egypt was a province of the roman republic she must become a province of the french republic but i think on top of that, what is also bubbling away here is the idea that actually Egypt is much older than Greece or Rome. And that if you want to study the real roots of culture, of civilization, you know, it's not enough to go to Rome. It's not enough to go to Athens. You've actually got to go to Egypt. And it's still pretty much terra incognita. People have started going there, but there's a sense that there are vast, vast treasures just waiting to be found. And so I think that that also is absolutely a part of it. Well, yeah, that's one thing, sort of imaginative leap you have to make. They don't know what we
我的意思是，这是一种相当惊人的履历，但他说——他说埃及曾是罗马共和国的一个省，她必须成为法兰克福共和国（应为法兰西共和国）的一个省。但我觉得除此之外，这里还在酝酿着另一种思想，那就是埃及实际上比希腊或罗马还要古老。如果你想研究文化、文明的真正根源，你知道，只去罗马是不够的。只去雅典是不够的。你实际上必须去埃及。而且它在很大程度上仍然是一片未知之地（terra incognita）。人们已经开始去那里了，但人们有一种感觉，那就是有极其庞大的宝藏正等待着被发掘。所以我觉得这也是其中绝对的一部分。好吧，是的，这是其一，你必须做出某种富有想象力的飞跃。他们不知道我们
know. So you're right. There are not the detailed descriptions and pictures of Egyptian antiquities that we're all familiar with that British or indeed children anywhere in the world grow up with these days so there's a real sense of this is a not just an amazing story because it's not just an invasion it's not just a blow against the British it's a genuine voyage of discovery and that's why Napoleon assembles 151 savants kind of intellectuals yeah so it's not just got tens of thousands of troops in the fleet he's got all these boffins to come with a hot air balloon and they are i didn't read where's the hot air balloon i didn't know a hot air balloon he takes um do they do they does it
所知道的事情。所以你是对的。没有我们今天英国人、或者说世界各地儿童都在其陪伴下长大的那种对埃及古物的详细描述和图片，所以这里有一种真正的感觉：这不仅是一个了不起的故事，因为它不仅是一次入侵，不仅是对英国的一次打击，它是一次真正的发现之旅，这就是为什么拿破仑集结了151位学者（savants）——某种知识分子，对吧？所以他的舰队里不仅有成千上万的军队，他还带了所有这些书呆子（boffins）带着一个热气球来，而且他们——我没有读到——热气球在哪里？我不知道有热气球，他带了——
go up they use it they launch it in cairo and everyone's very impressed and they take a load of printing presses including including one and the only arabic printing press in the whole of europe do you know where that was uh salisbury no it was the vatican brilliantly so it got nicked from the vatican when he when he occupied i did not know that um and but but he's also they've got a plan they know that there was once because of this thing about india they know or they think they know that there was once, because of this thing about India, they know or they think they know that there was once a canal, weren't they? Yeah, going under eyes.
它们真的升空了吗？他们使用了它，他们在开罗放飞了它，每个人都印象深刻，他们带了一大堆印刷机——其中包括一台、也是整个欧洲唯一一台阿拉伯语印刷机。你知道那是在哪里吗？呃，索尔兹伯里？不，是在梵蒂冈，太妙了！所以当他占领那里时，它是从梵蒂冈被偷来的。我不知道这一点。呃，但是——但是他们也有一个计划，他们知道曾经——因为关于印度的这件事，他们知道——或者他们认为他们知道曾经——因为关于印度的这件事，他们知道或者他们认为他们知道曾经有一条运河，不是吗？是的，穿过地峡。
Across the, yeah, the Suez Canal. And they are thinking, well, if we can do something like that and find out where it was, then that will give us a massive advantage over the British. We can get to India and we'll control, you know, the sort of hinge of Eurasia, basically. Yeah, so it's geopolitical, it's colonialist, it's romantic, it's personal for Napoleon. He wants to become the new Alexander. It's political for the Directory. They want to get rid of this overambitious general. It is also that it's still kind of i think warmed by the the embers of revolutionary fervor so um there's this guy dominique arago who who says he lists the reasons
穿过，是的，苏伊士运河。他们在想，如果我们能做类似的事情并找出它曾经在哪里，那么这将给我们带来巨大的优势，超越英国。我们可以到达印度，我们将控制欧亚大陆的枢纽，基本上就是这样。是的，所以它是地缘政治的、殖民主义的、浪漫的、也是拿破仑个人的。他想成为新的亚历山大。对督政府来说它是政治性的。他们想摆脱这个野心勃勃的将军。这也是因为我认为它仍然被革命激情的余烬所温暖。所以——
why the french should go to egypt and he says it's to offer a suckering hand to an unhappy people to free them from the brutalizing yoke under which they have grown for centuries and finally to endow them without delay with all the benefits of european civilization which is nice so there is this sense that the french when they go there see themselves as kind of the you know the the embodiments of the of the future with it um they're bringing liberty they're bringing enlightenment i'm sure you've got it, Tom, but when they embark at Toulon on the 19th of May, 1798,
有这个名叫多米尼克·阿拉戈（Dominique Arago）的家伙，他列出了法国人应该去埃及的原因，他说这是为了向一个不幸的人民伸出援助之手，将他们从几个世纪以来一直承受的野蛮枷锁中解放出来，最后，毫不迟延地赋予他们欧洲文明的一切福祉。这很好。所以有一种感觉，法国人去那里时，把自己视为未来的化身，带着它——
Bonaparte gives this extraordinary address to his troops. Soldiers, he says, you're one of the wings of the French army. You've made war on the mountains, on the plains, in the cities. It remains for you to fight on the seas. The Roman legions that you sometimes imitated but no longer equaled fought carthage now on this same sea and now on
他们带来了自由，他们带来了启蒙。我确信你找到了，汤姆，但当他们在1798年5月19日于土伦启程时，
the plains of zammer soldiers sailors you've been neglected until this day today the greatest concern of the republic is for you the genius of liberty which made you at her birth the arbiter of europe wants to be the genius of the seas and of the furthest nations. So you've got so much going on there. There's a lot going on there. But all that stuff about Carthage and Zama and stuff, I mean, it's great. Well, Carthage is Britain. Yes, clearly.
波拿巴向他的部队发表了这篇非同寻常的演讲。士兵们，他说，你们是法兰克福（应为法兰西）军队的翼侧之一。你们在山脉、平原、城市中作战。你们还剩下在海上作战。你们有时模仿但不再匹敌的罗马军团曾在同一海上、现在又在扎马平原上与迦太基作战。士兵们、水手们，直到今天你们一直被忽视，今天共和国最关心的是你们。那个在你们诞生时使你们成为欧洲仲裁者的自由天才，想要成为海洋和最远国度的天才。所以你在那里看到了如此多的内容。那里发生了很多事情。但所有关于迦太基、扎马之类的事情，我的意思是，这很棒。嗯，迦太基就是英国。是的，很明显。
The commercial naval power. Right. Who must be destroyed. They care only for money and killing children. Exactly. Yeah. Exactly. But also, absolutely, the idea of liberating egypt which is um
那个商业海军强国。没错。必须被消灭。他们只关心金钱和杀害儿童。完全正确。是的。完全正确。但同时，绝对地，解放埃及的想法是——
well it's it's supposedly a province of the ottoman empire but effectively it's ruled by the mamaluks who are there's this kind of incredible dynasty of of slaves who get bought in mainly from the caucasus well there weren't slaves recently were they i mean there were slaves hundreds of years earlier presumably no but they continue to buy them so they're still buying them yes so they get bought in and they they live as slaves recently, were they? I mean, they were slaves hundreds of years earlier, presumably. No, but they continue to buy them. So they're still buying them? Yes, so they get bought in and they live as slaves as children and they're kind of raised to become Mamelukes. And then I think when they kind of sprout a beard or something
嗯，这——这据说是奥斯曼帝国的一个省，但实际上它是由马穆鲁克统治的，他们是一群主要从高加索买来的奴隶，这种王朝极其不可思议——好吧，他们不久前还是奴隶吗？我的意思是，那是几百年前的奴隶，大概吧？不，但他们继续购买他们，所以他们仍然在购买他们？是的，所以他们被买来，他们作为奴隶生活——不久前还是奴隶吗？我的意思是，那是几百年前的奴隶，大概吧？不，但他们继续购买他们。所以他们仍然在购买他们？是的，所以他们被买来，他们作为奴隶生活，作为儿童，他们被抚养长大成为马穆鲁克。然后我想当他们长出胡子或者别的什么
and they've done their military training, then they're elevated to basically they kind of become free. But I mean, it's kind of very odd. You know, you serve your apprenticeship as a slave and then you end up as a kind of ruler of Egypt. And that is, you know, that's a tradition that goes back to the 13th century, that they defeat the Mongols, kind of one of the great decisive battles in world history. But before that, they had defeated the crusade of Louis VII, which is a kind of precursor. So the French have got unfinished business, haven't they, basically?
并且完成了他们的军事训练后，他们就被晋升为基本上获得自由的人。但我的意思是，这非常奇怪。你知道，你作为奴隶度过了你的学徒期，然后你最终成为了埃及的统治者。而这——这是一个可以追溯到13世纪的传统，他们击败了蒙古人，这是世界历史上最具决定性的战役之一。但在那之前，他们击败了路易七世的十字军东征，这是一个前兆。所以法国人有未竟的事业，对吧，基本上？
There's an incredible kind of snuff of weird historical parallels echoes inspirations going on here and it's just incredibly napoleonic and one of the reasons why napoleon is such an amazing figure is that he kind of surfs the waves of all these kind of different trends and ideas um and does it with such kind of self-confidence that he gets the world to accept him on his own estimation. Absolutely. It's because he has that sense that great historical characters, I mean, I don't know, Alexander Churchill, let's say, has this too, that he is a figure in history. Napoleon has it from a very young age. And certainly when he sails to Egypt, he's consciously reenacting classical precedence
这里有一种令人难以置信的奇怪历史平行、回声、灵感的碰撞，而且这简直太拿破仑了。拿破仑之所以能成为如此了不起的人物，原因之一就在于他乘着所有这些不同趋势和思想的浪潮，并且带着如此强大的自信，以至于他让全世界都按照他自己的评估来接受他。绝对是的。这是因为他有一种感觉：伟大的历史人物——我的意思是，我不知道，亚历山大、丘吉尔，比如说，也有这种感觉——他是历史中的一个人物。拿破仑从很小的时候就有这种感觉。当然，当他乘船前往埃及重演古典先例时，他是有意识的，
and he thinks he's writing an entirely new chapter in world history and he is as he does yes absolutely absolutely so he makes a promise right from the beginning doesn't he
他认为他正在世界历史上书写一个全新的篇章，而且他的确在这样做，是的，绝对是的。所以他从一开始就做出承诺，不是吗？
he basically pretty much before I think he even lands in Alexandria there's obviously this issue that all his campaigns so far have been against other european christian nations so this is the first time they are they are going you know they they're not just going to an unknown land they're going to a muslim land and that gives it a real edge that it hasn't had so so so napoleon is always issuing these kind of streams of um announcements to to the egyptians in this kind of ludicrously
他基本上——我想甚至在他登陆亚历山大港之前——显然存在这样一个问题，即他迄今为止所有的战役都是针对其他欧洲基督教国家的，所以这是他们第一次前往——他们不仅是去一个未知的地方，他们是去一个穆斯林国家，这赋予了它一种前所未有的犀利感。所以——所以拿破仑总是向埃及人发表这种连珠炮般的公告，用这种荒谬的
cod quranic language um a bit i remember it's kind of uh in the wake of 9-11 there was a real trend for western politicians to do all that you know peace be upon him and god the all-merciful and all that kind of stuff um and napoleon so napoleon is really the first Western leader who does this. So there's loads of kind of, have we not for centuries been the friends of the Grand Sunni? May God accomplish his desires and the enemy of his enemies. I mean, it's so great. And then when he actually gets to Cairo, he has this and he's talking to an imam. And he, glory to Allah, there is no God but God.
模仿古兰经的语言——有一点我记得，在9-11事件之后，西方政客中曾有一种真正的趋势，去做所有那些“愿他平安”、“至仁至慈的真主”之类的事情，拿破仑真的是第一个这样做的西方领导人。所以有大量类似的内容：难道我们几个世纪以来不是大苏丹的朋友吗？愿真主实现他的愿望，愿真主成为他敌人的敌人。我的意思是，这太棒了。然后当他真正到达开罗时，他有了这个——他在跟一个伊玛目交谈。他说：赞美真主，除真主外别无神灵。
Muhammad is his prophet, and I am one of his friends. That's great. And I don't think anyone is really fooled by this. But he says at one point, doesn't he, I want you to tell the people, he says, Qadis, sheikhs, imams, Chorbadjis, and notables of the nation, I ask you to tell the people that we are the true friends of the muslims wasn't it us who destroyed the knights of malta wasn't it us who destroyed the pope who used to say that he had a duty to make war on muslims
穆罕默德是他的先知，我是他的朋友。这太棒了。而且我认为没有人真的被这个愚弄了。但他有一次说，不是吗？我希望你告诉人民，他说：卡迪（法官）、谢赫、伊玛目、乔尔巴吉（Chorbadjis，土耳其军衔）和国家的显贵们，我请你们告诉人民，我们是穆斯林真正的朋友。难道不是我们摧毁了马耳他骑士团吗？难道不是我们摧毁了那个曾说有义务向穆斯林发动战争的教皇吗？
wasn't it us who have all times been friends to the great lord and enemies to his enemies i mean does anybody believe this tom the stuff about i'm the enemy of the pope i love gala i'm no is this all i mean to appear does everybody see through it do you think well i i think um yes i think basically people do see through i mean in private napoleon is is much i mean he so he takes the quran with him he takes his library with him herodotusus, all kinds of stuff. And he categorizes it under various different labels. And he catalogs the Quran, not under religion, but under politics, which I think kind of gives you a kind of indication as to how he's reading this. And he, I mean, you know, in private conversation, he's absolutely upfront, he kind of says,
难道不是我们一直以来都是大老爷（指苏丹）的朋友、他敌人的敌人吗？我的意思是，汤姆，有人相信这个吗？关于“我是教皇的敌人，我热爱伊斯兰，我不是”的这些东西？所有这些——我的意思是，所有人都能看穿它吗？你觉得呢？好吧，我——我想，是的，我认为基本上人们能看穿它。我的意思是，在私下里，拿破仑要——他随身携带《古兰经》，他随身携带他的图书馆，希罗多罗（希罗多德）、各种各样的东西。他把它们分类在各种不同的标签下。他把《古兰经》分类，不是归在宗教下，而是归在政治下，我觉得这在某种程度上让你对他是如何阅读这本书有了一种了解。并且他——我的意思是，你知道，在私下交谈中，他完全是直言不讳的，他有点说，
you know, we must lull this fanaticism. You know, we must kind of lull it to sleep so that we can then eradicate it. So he is very in private, self-consciously feeling that he's going there as a servant of the Enlightenment. But in public, he is talking about being the friend of Islam. And I think that to a degree, he's kind of kidding himself. And I think that this is one of the reasons why it's such an interesting topic going into the into the present day because i think he does feel that um that the enlightenment and the ideals of the french revolution provide a kind of neutral place where people who have emancipated themselves from christianity can be neutral between christianity and islam and superior to both
你知道，我们必须让这种狂热平息下来。你知道，我们必须让它沉睡，以便我们随后能够根除它。所以他私下里非常有意识地觉得他是作为启蒙运动的仆人去那里的。但在公开场合，他却在谈论自己是伊斯兰教的朋友。而且我认为在某种程度上，他在自欺欺人。并且我认为这就是为什么这是一个进入当今时代也非常有趣的话题的原因之一，因为我认为他确实觉得，呃，启蒙运动和法国大革命的理想提供了一个中立的场所，在这个场所里，那些已经从基督教中解放出来的人可以在基督教和伊斯兰教之间保持中立，并且超越两者。
and this becomes kind of the controlling conceit really of a french secularism right the way up into the present day the idea that the french secular revolutionary state is superior to and can absorb into its fabric kind of different cultures different civilizations yeah that's very familiar isn't it but let's let's part that for a second. We get back into the sacral and the secular. Very familiar topics to some in the second half. So they land. They land in sort of Alexandria.
而这成为了法国世俗主义的一种控制性观念，一直延续到今天——法国世俗革命国家优于并能够将其吸收进自身的结构中的这种观念，即不同的文化、不同的文明，是的，这非常熟悉，不是吗？但是让我们暂且把这个搁置一秒钟。我们回到神圣与世俗的话题。这在下半场对某些人来说是非常熟悉的话题。所以他们登陆了。他们在亚历山大港附近登陆。
They march across the desert towards Cairo. And basically, they're about nine miles from the Great Pyramid from Giza when they meet the Mamluk army and this is one of these almost science fiction moments in history where you have a very very modern, well trained
他们穿过沙漠向开罗行军。基本上，当他们遇到马穆鲁克军队时，他们距离吉萨的大金字塔大约有九英里。这是一个几乎带有科幻色彩的历史时刻：你有一支非常、非常现代、训练有素、
well equipped European army facing a Mamluk army that basically is technologically much more backward, it is doing kind of mad cavalry charges towards guns and stuff like that. But it's not helped itself by having divided itself in two. Because there are effectively two Mamluk leaders. And one of the armies ends up on the wrong side of the Nile.
装备精良的欧洲军队，面对着一支在技术上要落后得多的马穆鲁克军队，它正向着大炮等武器发起疯狂的骑兵冲锋。但它因为把自己一分为二而没有帮到自己。因为实际上有两个马穆鲁克领袖。其中一支军队最终落在了尼罗河的错误一侧。
Yeah, 40,000 of the Mamluks don't even get to the battle. Yeah. But it's such a kind of dramatic setting that you've got the great citadel built by saladin of cairo across the nile on the left side as the french facing it and in the distance there are arguments about whether they could actually have seen the pyramids supposedly they couldn't see the pyramids but in all the paintings every painting that's done the battle because of course there's tons of paintings of the battle of the pyramids and all of them they're basically fighting in the shadow of the pyramids aren't they i mean
是的，4万名马穆鲁克甚至都没能赶上这场战斗。是的，但这是一个如此戏剧化的场景：开罗由萨拉丁建造的大城堡横跨尼罗河，在法军面向它的左侧，而在远处，关于他们是否真的能看到金字塔，人们曾有过争论。据说明明看不到金字塔，但在所有的画作中——关于这场战斗的每一幅画，因为当然有大量的关于金字塔战役的画作——在所有的画作中，他们基本上都是在金字塔的阴影下战斗，不是吗？我的意思是，
they might as well have and you have this great thing from napoleon that soldiers 40 years of 40 centuries of history look down upon you uh and and again people have the assumption has been that this is retrospective but actually that apparently there's a letter that was that was written the day after the battle that that basically all right so basically implies that Napoleon did so there's a very kind of histrionic self-conscious sense that this is an amazing place for a civilizational battle
他们本可以这么做。并且你有拿破仑的那句名言：士兵们，40个世纪的历史正俯视着你们，呃，同样，人们曾假设这是事后追记的，但显然有一封信是在战役结束后第二天写的，基本上暗示了拿破仑确实说过这话。所以有一种非常戏剧化的、有意识的感觉，认为这是进行一场文明之战的绝佳地点。
and of course Napoleon wins it and he occupies Cairo the Mamluks retreat down the Nile and Napoleon sends they retreat up the Nile surely yeah up the Nile and Napoleon sends... They retreat up the Nile, surely. Yeah, up the Nile under a very distinguished general
当然拿破仑赢了，他占领了开罗，马穆鲁克沿尼罗河退却，拿破仑派——他们是沿尼罗河向上退却的，当然。是的，沿尼罗河向上退却。他们确实是沿尼罗河向上退却的，在一位杰出的将军
called Dessay who pursues the Mamluks up the Nile. And again, just kind of looking ahead to when we come on to the Egyptology bit, they take various savants with them as they go up the Nile to pursue them. But Napoleon is now in charge of Cairo and it's all looking good.
德赛（Dessay）的率领下，他率军沿尼罗河追击马穆鲁克。同样，稍微展望一下当我们谈到埃及学的那一部分时，他们沿着尼罗河追击时带上了各种学者。但拿破仑现在掌控了开罗，一切看起来都很不错。
But at this point, then, yeah, but then as if we didn't have enough good characters in this. So they had evaded the British, hadn't they, to get to Egypt. They had invaded the Royal Navy.
但就在这时，等等——就好像我们这里的优秀人物还不够多一样。所以他们躲过了英国人，对吧，为了到达埃及。他们躲避了皇家海军。
We're basically chasing them. So Nelson had been given orders to basically stop the Armada. And it's a fast Armada. mean it's it's um it's it's 335 ships it's you know hundreds of guns cavalry men i mean it's it's kind of almost up there with xerxes invasion it's it's on a vast scale and nelson is just harrying around trying to find it and there's one kind of excruciating moment, I think, when they're pulling out of Malta, which Napoleon has captured. And the French can hear Nelson's ships kind of sounding cannon through the night
我们基本上在追赶他们。所以纳尔逊曾奉命去阻止这支无敌舰队。这是一支快速的舰队——我的意思是，它——它是——它是335艘船，你知道，数百门大炮、骑兵——我的意思是，这几乎可以跟薛西斯的入侵相提并论，它的规模极其宏大，而纳尔逊只是四处搜寻试图找到它。有一个极其痛苦的时刻，我想，当他们撤出拿破仑已经占领的马耳他时。
so that the British squadron can keep track of each other. And they're just sailing silently so that Nelson won't know that they're going past. So Nelson is furious about this. Tom, this is so patrick o'brien i can't believe you don't like those books so jack our producer loves these books and he like me is disgusted that you are rude about patrick o'brien and broke it's too much i've said this before it's
法国人可以听到纳尔逊的船只整夜鸣炮的声音，这样英国分舰队就能追踪彼此的位置。而他们只是默默地航行，这样纳尔逊就不会知道他们正从旁驶过。所以纳尔逊对此勃然大怒。汤姆，这太帕特里克·奥布里安（Patrick O'Brian）了，我真不敢相信你不喜欢那些书。所以我们的制作人杰克喜欢这些书，他和我和一样，对你对帕特里克·奥布里安及其作品的粗鲁态度感到厌恶。这太过了，我以前说过，这
too much rope but you know if it was just nelson like that i'd be all over that but in the end nelson works out where napoleon's fleet is and it's been um been, it's kind of been stationed in Abakir Bay, which is off Cairo in the mouth of the Nile. And the French fleet have moored there because there are very, very narrow shallows that they think no fleet could get round. And so essentially, were the British fleet to be able to go past these shallows,
太离谱了。但你知道，如果只是纳尔逊这样的话，我完全可以接受，但最终纳尔逊弄清了拿破仑舰队的位置，它被——被驻扎在阿布基尔湾（Abakir Bay），位于开罗附近的尼罗河口。法国舰队之所以停泊在那里，是因为那里有非常、非常狭窄的浅滩，他们认为没有任何舰队能够绕过去。所以基本上，如果英国舰队能够穿过这些浅滩，
the flank of the French fleet would be terminally exposed and that of course is exactly what Nelson does. So Nelson divides his attack, half go one way half go, you know, they cut off the French so they're basically between the land and the French now
法国舰队的侧翼将彻底暴露，而这当然正是纳尔逊所做的。所以纳尔逊分兵进攻，一半走这边，一半走那边——你知道，他们切断了法国人，所以他们现在基本上夹在陆地和法国舰队之间。
and it's about a three hour battle, I think the Battle of the Nile and the sort of high point of it is when Nelson himself towards the end is hit, isn't he? He's shot. And he's already lost one eye before. So he's hit quite – I mean, people say it's only a flesh wound, but it sounds quite bad. Like his skull is exposed. He had that famous line, didn't he, that before the battle that I will gain either a peerage or Westminster Abbey.
这场尼罗河战役大约持续了三个小时，其中最高潮的时刻是纳尔逊本人在临近结束时中弹了，不是吗？他中弹了。他之前已经失去了一只眼睛。所以他伤得很重——我的意思是，人们说这只是皮外伤，但听起来相当严重。就像他的头骨都露出来了。他有过那句名言，不是吗，在战役开始前，他宣称：我要么赢得一个贵族爵位，要么去威斯敏斯特教堂。
Exactly. So he's kind of ready to die. And it's interesting that in this battle there are quite a number of, well, kind of echoes of the future story to come. So there's one Lieutenant Thomas Hardy, who has seized some Egyptian pilots who then are used to help negotiate the shoals. And there's also HMS Bellerophon, which is actually the British ship that gets most damaged. And it kind of ends up drifting off. And of course, Bellerophon in the long run
没错。所以他已经做好了牺牲的准备。有趣的是，在这场战役中，有相当多的——嗯，可以说是未来故事的回声。比如有一位托马斯·哈迪（Thomas Hardy）中尉，他抓获了一些埃及领航员，然后这些领航员被用来协助通过浅滩。还有“柏勒罗丰号”（HMS Bellerophon）战舰，它实际上是受损最严重的英国战舰。它最后漂流开了。当然，“柏勒罗丰号”在长期来看
is the ship that will pick up Napoleon after Waterloo. And it's the cause of a famous poem, is it not? Is it? Yes. So Lorient, the flagship that Napoleon had sailed sailed on the vast ship and um it gets pounded and pounded it's got lots of gunpowder on and it explodes and the admiral
就是滑铁卢战役后接载拿破仑的船只。它也引发了一首著名的诗，不是吗？是吗？是的。“东方号”（Lorient），拿破仑乘坐的旗舰，一艘巨大的船，呃，它遭到了一轮又一轮的轰炸，船上有很多火药，它爆炸了，该舰的舰队司令、
of the ship the commander of the ship casabianca uh he dies there and his son dies and his son is standing on the deck and refuses to leave until he's been told by his father to leave. And so you get this famous poem, the boy stood on the burning deck, went all but he had fled. The flame that lit the battle's wreck shone round him, the dead. And do you know Eric Malcom's version of that? I do not. I do not. I should. The boy stood on the burning deck. His lips were all a quiver. He gave a cough. His leg fell off and floated down the river. Very nice.
舰长卡萨比安卡（Casabianca）在那里牺牲了，他的儿子也牺牲了。他的儿子站在甲板上，拒绝离开，直到他的父亲命令他离开。于是你得到了这首著名的诗：“那男孩站在燃烧的甲板上，其余的人都已逃亡。照亮战斗残骸的火焰，在他四周闪耀，伴着死去的亡灵。”你知道埃里克·莫尔康（Eric Malcom）的那个版本吗？我不知道。我不知道。我应该知道的。“那男孩站在燃烧的甲板上，他的嘴唇不住地颤抖。他咳嗽了一声，腿掉了下来，顺着河流漂走了。”非常不错。
Very nice. Not a river, unfortunately. But there you go. So Nelson is hit. He's got lost one eye already. A flap of skin falls down and obscures his other eye. So he can't see anything. He's very frightened.
非常不错。可惜不是一条河。但就是这样。所以纳尔逊中弹了。他已经失去了一只眼睛。一块皮肉垂下来挡住了他的另一只眼睛。所以他什么也看不见。他非常害怕。
He shouts, I'm killed. Remember me to my wife. And then he's taken down. Emma Hamilton. Yeah. And the surgeon says, actually, you're fine. You you know it's just a kind of it looks back a man up get back up there he's snowflake so back he goes up and uh they win but there's a great so it's an absolute crushing victory so almost all the french ships of the line that's the big warships either captured or destroyed it is it shatters the French fleet. There's a lovely detail afterwards.
他大喊：我死了。请代我向我的妻子问好。然后他被扶了下去。艾玛·汉密尔顿（Emma Hamilton）。是的。外科医生说：其实你没事。你知道，这只是一种——看起来有点糟，振作点，回到上面去。他真是个“雪花”（娇气包）！所以他回到了上面，呃，他们赢了。这是一个巨大的——这是一场绝对粉碎性的胜利，所以几乎所有的法国主力舰——也就是那些大型战舰——要么被俘，要么被毁，它彻底粉碎了法国舰队。战后有一个很可爱的细节。
So Nelson is still quite blinded. He can't really see properly. So he's going around presenting gifts to the other captains and to people who distinguish themselves in the battle. And because he can't see, he gives a toothpick to a man who's had his teeth blown out. And to a man, do you know what he gave a man whose nose had been shot off?
所以纳尔逊的视力仍然很模糊。他看得不是很清楚。所以他四处走动，向其他船长以及在战役中表现杰出的人赠送礼物。因为他看不见，他把一支牙签送给了一个牙齿被炸飞的人。而对于一个人——你知道他把什么送给了一个鼻子被炸掉的人吗？
No. He gave him a snuff box. Oh, goodness. Yeah. Anyway, so Nelson recovers from that mishap. And basically, at that very moment, so the invasion is not very old, but that moment,
不。他送给他一个鼻烟壶。哦，天哪。不管怎样，纳尔逊从那次事故中恢复过来了。基本上，就在那个时刻——所以入侵还不是很久，但就在那个时刻，
you know, the French are doomed, really, from then, aren't they? Napoleon says... He's told what's happened and he says we no longer have a navy well we'll have to stay here or leave as great men just as the ancients did now of course people who listen to our alexander podcast exactly will remember that alexander had sent away his navy yeah after invading asia minor or indeed cortez burning his ships and cortez burning his ships, exactly. So there is a kind of...
你知道，法国人从那时起就注定要失败了，不是吗？拿破仑说……他被告知发生了什么，然后他说：我们不再拥有海军了，好吧，我们要么留在这里，要么像古人那样作为伟人离开。当然，听过我们的亚历山大播客的人，就会记得亚历山大曾遣散他的海军，
He'd be aware of both those parallels. Exactly. And he would almost... You know, Napoleon being Napoleon, he would almost welcome this because he would see it as a chance to prove his worth and valour. I mean, I think one of the weird things
在入侵小亚细亚之后，或者正如科尔特斯烧毁他的船只一样，科尔特斯烧毁了他的船只，正是如此。所以存在着一种——他会意识到这两种相似之处。正是如此。拿破仑就是拿破仑，他几乎会欢迎这一点，因为他会把它视为证明自己价值和勇气的机会。我的意思是，我认为埃及展览奇怪的事情之一是，它有点——
about the Egypt exhibition is that it kind of... It serves as an overture to Napoleon's campaigns in europe and of course you get trafalgar where nelson again destroys the french fleet and napoleon's reaction is to blaze off and win the battle of australis so i don't think that napoleon feels that this is terminal i mean he's he's still ready to go the full alexander and that's basically what he does so he's in cairo he has strange egyptian
它成了拿破仑欧洲战役的前奏，当然你会遇到特拉法加海战，纳尔逊再次摧毁了法国舰队，而拿破仑的反应是怒火中烧并赢得奥斯特利茨战役，所以我不认为拿破仑觉得这是致命的——我的意思是，他仍然准备好完全效仿亚历山大，这基本上就是他所做的。所以他在开罗，他举行了奇怪的埃及
um uh sort of festivities doesn't he where people are cheering him and muhammad together well so the french the french fund celebrations for muhammad's birthday that's it yeah to celebrate i think it's the seventh or i think seventh revolutionary year which begins i think in september they have a massive, great public celebration where they, they kind of raise a triumphal arch. That's right. And they kind of put revolutionary slogans and Quranic slogans on it.
呃——某种庆祝活动，不是吗？人们在那里欢呼，庆祝穆罕默德的生日——噢，对，法国人资助了穆罕默德生日的庆祝活动，就是这样，为了庆祝——我想是第七个或者我以为是第七个革命年，我想它始于九月份，他们举行了一场盛大无比的公众庆祝活动，他们——他们竖起了一座凯旋门。没错。而且他们在上面写上了革命标语和《古兰经》的标语。
And they have a vast meal where everyone is supposed to sit down. So the Egyptians, as well as the French and next to the placemats, they include quotations from the Quran and the Declaration of Human Rights. It's so strange. Yeah, but, I mean, that is, you know, that's where the French Republic basically still is. I mean, it's this idea that you can combine
他们举行了一场盛大的宴会，每个人都被要求入座。所以埃及人，还有法国人，在座位卡旁边，他们印上了《古兰经》和《人权宣言》的引言。太奇怪了。是的，但是，我的意思是，这就是——法兰西共和国基本上仍然所处的位置。我的意思是，这是一种你可以将法国大革命与——比如说——伊斯兰教结合起来，并且两者之间不存在文明冲突的想法。但这里也有第三个要素，不是吗？那就是它在某种程度上被当作一场罗马式的凯旋仪式。他们穿过一座凯旋门，这有点像马克·安东尼在亚历山大港组织的那种凯旋式。
the French Revolution with, say, Islam and that there's no kind of civilizational tension there. But there is also this third element, isn't there, which is that it's sort of done as a Roman, there's a bit of a Roman triumph. They go through a triumphal arch, and it's sort of, it's a bit like the sort of triumphs that Mark Antony had organized in Alexandria.
你知道，那种他在与克利奥帕特拉鬼混时引入的罗马凯旋式。好吧，拿破仑确实跟一个女人有染，不是吗？他称她为他的克利奥帕特拉。正是如此，他给自己起了各种各样的称号，不是吗？他——有一次他被授予了“阿里·波拿巴”的头衔，他称自己为“真主的宠儿”。这一切都是这种角色扮演（cosplay），
You know, that sort of, he'd imported the Roman triumph when he was shacked out with Cleopatra. Well, Napoleon has an affair, doesn't he, with a woman who he he calls his cleopatra exactly and he's calling himself all kinds of things isn't he he's uh at one point he's been given the title ali bonaparte which he's calling himself the favorite of allah this is all this kind of cosplay yeah it is this is exactly what it is but it's basically he's a man in a computer game but again so so basically a month after you know this rights of man quranic stuff um there's a there's a rebellion in cairo yeah so clearly no one in cairo is kind of wearing this at all it's absolutely
是的，这正是它的本质，但基本上他就像一个电脑游戏里的人。但同样——所以基本上就在这个《人权宣言》和《古兰经》标语事件的一个月后，开罗爆发了一场叛乱。是的，所以很明显，开罗没有一个人买账，这完全是
jibberish napoleon's response is absolutely brutal yeah mean, he fires cannonballs at the Al-Azhar Mosque, which is, you know, possibly the most significant mosque in the whole of Islam. I mean, it's... Do you know what he says? They say that God will save us. And he says... Yeah, too late.
胡说八道。拿破仑的反应绝对是残酷的。我的意思是，他用炮弹轰击爱资哈尔清真寺（Al-Azhar Mosque），这是——你知道，可能是整个伊斯兰教中最有意义的清真寺。我的意思是，它——你知道他说什么吗？他们说真主会拯救我们。他说……是的，太晚了。
God is too late. God is too late. You have begun, now I will finish it. Yeah. And he orders all the heads of the rebels to be piled up in you know uh in a great square and the corpses to be thrown in the nile and it's actually very very kind of battle of algiers and again this kind of the the tension between the claims to a kind of universal
真主太迟了。真主太迟了。你们已经开始了，现在我来收尾。是的。他下令将所有叛军的头颅堆积在——你知道的，在一个大广场上，并将尸体扔进尼罗河。这其实非常、非常像《阿尔及尔之战》，而且这种——追求一种法兰西共和国所体现的普遍启蒙与兄弟情谊的诉求，与愿意非常残暴地镇压反对这一诉求的人之间的这种张力，是从拿破仑一直延续到阿尔及利亚（战争）的主题。有些人会说，这就是欧洲殖民主义的主题，不是吗？它是一方面是那种——但我认为，对于法国来说，它更具意识形态色彩。我的意思是，在英国，他们当然也用大炮把人轰成碎片以及诸如此类的事情，但他们当时并没有声称自己体现了启蒙运动的理想。
enlightenment and brotherhood that the french republic embodies and the kind of willingness to repress very brutally people who oppose that is a theme running from napoleon right the way up to the up up to the algebra some people would say that's the theme wouldn't they have european colonialism it is that on the one hand is the sort of but i think i think with france it's more ideological i mean in britain of course they're blasting people out of cannons and all kinds of things but they're not claiming at that point to embody enlightenment ideals no no you're right and i think that that's the kind of peculiar quality of tension you get with french imperialism yeah right from the beginning so he does this then he i mean we better sort of whiz through the rest of the some of the rest of the campaign anyway because he goes up to syria doesn't he he decides he's basically gonna he's
不，不，你是对的，我认为这正是法国帝国主义从一开始就具有的那种奇特的张力。所以他做了这些，然后他——我们最好还是快速浏览一下战役剩余的部分，因为他去了叙利亚，不是吗？他决定他基本上要——
gonna reenact the crusades so even though he's been cut off no fleet all this he thinks well i'll just keep going basically alexander style or i'll do a bit of richard the lionheart so he captures jaffa doesn't he and then he goes up to Acre which satisfyingly for for sort of John Bull types Richard the Ironheart had captured but Alex but um Napoleon doesn't manage to capture it does he because his troops will get played to be fair Richard the Ironheart captured it together with Philip the second that's true so we we mustn't um yeah that's true yeah but and and the basically the um so it's held by the Ottomans. An Ottoman relief force comes down, gets defeated at the Battle of Mount Tabor, which is very significant for Christians.
重演十字军东征，所以尽管他被切断了退路，没有舰队，诸如此类，但他心想，好吧，我还是继续吧，基本上是亚历山大大帝的风格，或者我学一点狮心王理查。所以他占领了雅法，不是吗？然后他北上阿卡，这对约翰·牛津这类人来说挺解气的，狮心王理查曾攻占过阿卡，但拿破仑……呃，拿破仑没能攻占它，不是吗？因为他的军队染上了瘟疫。公平地说，狮心王理查是在腓力二世的配合下攻占的，确实如此，所以我们不能……对，没错，但是基本上，呃，所以它被奥斯曼人控制了。奥斯曼帝国的增援部队南下，在他泊山战役中战败，这对基督徒来说意义重大。
It's where the Transfiguration is supposed to have happened. But there's a British commander, Sidney Smith, who's the guy who had... Had too long. Had too long. And essentially, he forces Napoleon to retreat. So again, kind of precursor of the retreat from Moscow, perhaps. Too long. And essentially he forces Napoleon to retreat. So again, kind of precursor of the retreat from Moscow. Very much. And even then, I think there must be a sense
据说那是耶稣显圣容的地方。不过有个英国指挥官悉尼·史密斯，就是那个……时间太久了。时间太久了。基本上，他迫使拿破仑撤退。所以这可以说是莫斯科撤退的某种先兆吧。时间太久了。基本上他迫使拿破仑撤退。所以这又可以说是从莫斯科撤退的先兆。确实如此。即便如此，我想一定有一种感觉……
in some of the French soldiers' minds, rather anticipating what's going to happen in 10 or 11 years, they must be thinking, what the hell are we doing over here? I mean, what's going on? Why are we trudging through this? We're meant to be defending the French Revolution
在某些法国士兵的心中，某种程度上预示着10年或11年后将要发生的事情，他们肯定在想，我们到底在鬼地方干什么？我的意思是，这到底是怎么回事？我们为什么要在这种地方艰难跋涉？我们本该是去捍卫法国大革命的……
and here we are kind of, you know, basically in these biblical landscapes. They've all got dysentery and typhoid and stuff, haven't they? So it's just an absolute nightmare. And Napoleon has done this kind of, you know, a bit like the kings would go in and touch people for the king's evil.
结果我们却来到了这种类似《圣经》风景的地方。他们都得了痢疾、伤寒之类的病，对吧？所以这简直是一场绝对的噩梦。拿破仑甚至做了那种……你知道的，有点像国王过去会去触摸病人以治愈“国王之病”的举动。
He's gone into plague wards and, you know, Diana style. But there's conflicting claims about it, aren't there? Some say he goes and embraces the soldiers and, you know, it's very... And others say he keeps a distance the whole time. Yeah, yes. He's masked up, basically. So again, this whole kind of myth-making is so self-conscious. And he says that had Acre fallen, had Sidney Smith not spiked his destiny,
他走进了鼠疫病房，你知道的，戴安娜王妃式的作风。但关于这件事有相互矛盾的说法，不是吗？有些人说他去拥抱了士兵，你知道的，非常……而另一些人则说他全程都保持着距离。对，是的。基本上他戴着口罩。所以这种造神运动整个过程都是如此自觉。他还说，要是阿卡陷落了，要是悉尼·史密斯没有破坏他的命运……
he would have carried on. He would have made them into the immortals, he says. So the guards that guarded the Persian kings, the ancient Persian kings. And that he would have won a new battle of Isis, the battle that Alexander defeated the Persian king. So Napoleon crossed that, but he didn't. So he had to go back.
他本可以继续前行。他说他会把他们变成不死军团。也就是守护波斯国王、古代波斯国王的卫队。并且他会赢得一场新的伊苏斯战役，也就是亚历山大击败波斯国王的那场战役。所以拿破仑跨过了那一步，但他没有成功。因此他不得不回去。
And that August 1799, he defeats another Ottoman invasion force at the second battle of Abakir Bay. He does indeed. He held a triumph, by the way, when he got back to Cairo, which is very, very Mark Ansley style behaviour. Like, I've just been defeated by the Parthians.
而在1799年8月，他在阿布基尔湾第二次战役中击败了另一支奥斯曼入侵部队。他确实做到了。顺便说一句，当他回到开罗时，他举行了一场凯旋仪式，这非常非常符合马克·安东尼式的行为。就像是，我刚刚被帕提亚人击败了。这真是个好消息。让我们庆祝一下。对，完全是这样。然后，当然，接着他就彻底颜面尽扫了，不是吗？我得说，这非常不符合亚历山大式的行为。他直接逃跑了。
It's great news. Let's celebrate. Yeah, exactly. And then, of course, and then he absolutely disgraces himself, doesn't he? Very un-Alexander behaviour, I have to say. He just runs away.
独自一人。好吧，他会说……好吧，他会说他是为了拯救法国才回去的。对，那是……好吧，他确实是这么说的。他说……
On his own. Well, he would say... Well, he would say that he was going back to save France. Yeah, that is... Well, that is what he said. He said,
法国正四面楚歌。我必须立即返回。但他基本上把其他所有人都抛在了身后。而且他还告诉他们，他要去尼罗河三角洲附近航行。他说，我只是去度个周末的小假。我出发了。
France is beleaguered. I must return immediately. But he basically leaves everybody else behind. And he also tells them he's going to go off sailing around the Nile Delta. He says, I'm just going to go on a little kind of weekend excursion. I'm off.
你知道让-巴蒂斯特·克莱贝尔吗？我知道。那个将军，他是怎么评价这件事的？哦，我不知道他是怎么说的。他说什么了？我引述一下，“这个混蛋拉了一裤子的屎。等我们回到法国，我们要把他的脸按进他自己的屎里。”哦，天哪。
Do you know the Jean-Baptiste Clébé? I do. The general, what he said about it. Oh, I don't know what he said. What did he say? I quote, the bastard has shat his britches full. When we get back to France, we will rub his face in his own shit. Oh, my gosh.
好吧，克莱贝尔没有回到法国，对吧？不，他没有。因为，在一个与当前趋势极其相似的引人入胜的呼应中，他被我们现在可能会称之为原教旨主义者的人刺杀了。一个原教旨主义者。一个实际上是库尔德人的人。所以他甚至不完全是……他曾在爱资哈尔清真寺学习，所以他有着极强的思想动机，他被极端化了，他……你知道他后来怎么样了吗？我知道，我知道，我来告诉听众他后来怎么样了……
Well, Clavier didn't get back to France, did he? No, he didn't. Because, again, in a kind of fascinating echo of current trends, he gets assassinated by what we'd perhaps now call a fundamentalist. A fundamentalist. A guy who's actually Kurdish. So he's not even... He'd been studying at the al-azhar so he's very ideologically motivated he's been radicalized and he and you know what happens to him i do i do i would tell the listeners what happens to
他被……太可怕了，他的右手被烧焦了，对吧？那是挥舞匕首的手。但随后他被处决的方式是，被刺穿在……对，一根钝木棍上，为了减慢过程，他们把他硬生生地塞到这个上面，靠他自己的体重，把它埋在泥土里，所以他就像那样坐在上面……对，所以他就在那里慢慢地下沉，慢慢地下沉到木棍上，他连一声都没吭，连一声都没吭。我简直不敢相信。你会吗？不会，因为有法国观察员说这极其令人印象深刻。这个人没有发出过一声尖叫，除了最后……
he is um horrible he is so his right hand is burned isn't it that's the right hand that wields the dagger but then he is killed by being impaled yeah on a blunt stick so to slow it down they sort of jam him onto this and his own weight and they bury it in the soil so he's kind of sitting there yeah so he's kind of sinking slowly sinking onto the stick which he makes not a sound makes not a sound. I can't believe that. Would you? No, because there are French observers who say this is incredibly impressive. This man never let out a cry, except then to kind of yell out
在最后大喊了一声“真主至大”。你知道花了多长时间吗？四个小时。对。问题是。谁会站在那里看四个小时这种事发生？我的意思是，现在的观赏性体育运动……
Allahu Akbar at the end. You know how long it took? Four hours. Yeah. Here's the thing. Who would stand there for four hours to watch this happening? I mean, spectator sports go.
有点无聊。好吧，特别是当你有选择的时候，你可以看热气球或者……完全正确，所以当克莱贝尔被这个可怜的家伙刺杀之后，呃，他随后由一个叫雅克-弗朗索瓦·梅努的家伙接替，这是一个很有意思的人物。他有点大腹便便、衣衫褴褛、长发披肩、不修边幅。但关于他有趣的是，他娶了一个埃及女人并皈依了伊斯兰教。所以他不再是雅克-弗朗索瓦·梅努……
It's kind of dull. Well, especially when you've got, you could watch hot air balloons or... exactly so when when clay big after he's been assassinated by this poor guy um he then gets succeeded by a guy called uh jacques francois menu who's an interesting figure he's kind of pot-bellied rather ramshackle long-haired disheveled kind of figure but what's interesting about him is that he's married an Egyptian woman and converted to Islam. So he stops being Jacques-Francois Menou
而是成为了阿卜杜拉·梅努。是吗？所以这非常……这就像是亚历山大的某个同伴变成了一个波斯总督，然后彻底融入当地。这就是为什么拿破仑对此大加赞赏，并认为这简直太棒了。对。拿破仑真的认为这太棒了。梅努先生后来怎么了？他回到了法国，呃……
and becomes Abdullah Menou. Does he? So that's very, that's like one of Alexander's sort of companions becoming a Persian satrap and going native. And that's why Napoleon approves of it and thinks it's brilliant. Yeah. Napoleon really thinks it's brilliant. What happens to Monsieur Menou? He goes back to france um he's
他，我想他得到了一些小职位，最后进了一家疯人院。哦，天哪。好吧，总比被木棍刺死要强，所以……完全正确，是的，完全正确。好吧，这就是拿破仑远征的故事，这在某种程度上是一场失败，因为英国人进驻并在埃及建立了政治存在。但法国人建立了一种文化存在。也许这正是我们在中场休息后应该探讨的话题。无论如何，广告之后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。
he's i think he gets some kind of minor post and he ends up in a lunatic asylum oh god well it's better than being impaled so exactly yes exactly okay so that's the story of uh the napoleonic expedition which is kind of a defeat because the british move in and establish a political presence in Egypt. But the French have established a cultural presence. And perhaps that's what we should come to after the break. Anyway, we'll see you after the ads. I'm Marina Hyde.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐即全部》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们还会拉开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的权限……
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets,
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。嗨，在我们回到埃及的拿破仑之前，呃，老听众们现在应该对 unherd.com 很熟悉了，这是赞助本播客的网络杂志，我们两人都为它写过稿，不是吗？确实如此，我过几天就要开始为 UnHerd 写一篇文章了。写关于什么的？我不知道我能不能告诉你，因为其他的约稿编辑……这是一个你会非常喜欢的题材。
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hi, before we return to napoleon in egypt um regular listeners by now should be familiar with unheard unherd.com which is the online magazine that's sponsoring the podcast and for whom both of us have written is that not so it is i'm about to start writing a piece for unheard in the next few days. What about? I don't know if I can tell you because other commissioning editors. It's about a subject that you will really enjoy.
好吧，那我拭目以待了。好的。对，但我不能告诉你是什么，因为其他人会偷走 UnHerd 的绝妙点子。好的，所以如果你想了解这些并阅读大量其他高质量的文章，我们为《历史即全部》的听众提供了一项特别优惠，即三个月的免费订阅……
Well, I'll look forward to that then. Okay. Yeah, but I can't tell you what it is because other people will steal Unheard's brilliant ideas. Okay. So if you want to find out about that and read lots of other quality writing, there's a special deal to Restless History listeners, three months free subscription,
随时可以取消，通常需要一英镑。访问 unheard.com 斜杠 rest，提醒一下，UnHerd 的拼写是 U-N-H-E-R-D，来领取优惠。我非常高兴能为它做广告，尤其是今天我们在谈论拿破仑在埃及的时候，因为我写过一篇文章。
which should be cancelled at any time, normally one pound. Go to unheard.com forward slash rest and reminder unheard is U-N-H-E-R-D to claim it. And I'm very happy to be advertising it, particularly today when we're talking about Napoleon in Egypt, because I wrote an essay.
对，这里写着“这是一首神曲”，但我不知道什么叫“神曲”。好吧，这里写着“这是一首神曲”，但我不知道……我知道什么叫“神曲”。好吧，它确实很棒，它确实是一首神曲，所以它的标题是《伊斯兰教与法国之间历史悠久的冲突》，开场白是，多米尼克，开场白是：1798年，拿破仑开始了自十字军东征时代以来法国对埃及的首次入侵。哇，真是非常应景，汤姆，你写的时候就知道我们要录这期播客吗？还是纯属巧合？不，那是前一阵子所有恐怖袭击之后的事。
Yeah, it says a banger here, but I don't know what a banger is. Well, it says a banger here but i don't know i know what a banger is well it is a banger it is a banger so it's it's the title is the age-old clash between islam and france and the opening sentence dominic the opening sentence in 1798 napoleon embarked on the first french invasion of egypt since the era of the crusades wow so very timely tom did you write that knowing that we were doing the podcast? Or was it a complete coincidence? No, it was a while back in the aftermath of all the terrorist attacks.
哦，对。对，没错。所以它是关于伊斯兰国的，为什么他们特别痛恨法国，甚至可能超过英国或其他欧洲国家。当伊斯兰国袭击巴塔克兰剧院和那个可怕的夜晚时，他们发布的责任声明中同时提到了十字军东征……
Oh, right. Yeah. Oh, yes. So it was about the Islamic State, why they particularly hated France more than perhaps even Britain or other European countries. When the Islamic State attacked the Bataclan and that terrible night, the message of responsibility they put out cited both the Crusades
以及潜台词中法国作为革命启蒙无神论共和国的角色。正是这种……争论的焦点在于，基督教的这种融合……
and by implication France's role as the revolutionary Enlightenment atheistical republic. And it's that kind of, the argument is that it's the fusion of those, you know, the Christian
和革命性的融合格外激怒了他们。没错。这种紧张关系绝对依然存在，因为 UnHerd 本周有一篇关于法国总统候选人或潜在候选人的文章……
and the revolutionary that particularly riles. Right. And that tension is definitely still there because UnHerd have an article this week about the French presidential candidate or would-be candidate,
埃里克·泽穆尔。汤姆，你一直在关注他吗？我有，就是那个长得像咕噜的人。对，他确实长得像咕噜。他来过伦敦。人们经常把他描述为极右翼，不是吗？他的一些言论相当……好吧，他是贝当元帅的粉丝……
Éric Zemmour. Have you been following him, Tom? I have, the one who looks like Gollum. Yes, he does look like Gollum. He came over to London. He's often described as being far right, isn't he? And some of his statements are quite... Well, he's a fan of Marshall Petain,
我认为这绝对有资格被称为极右翼。贝当元帅并不是我个人会去推崇的法国民族英雄。特别是考虑到埃里克·泽穆尔是个犹太人。这看起来非常奇怪。但如果你想理解其中一些复杂性和悖论，这也是一篇非常出色的特写。
which I think qualifies you to be far right. Marshall Petain's not the French national hero that I would reach for, personally. Particularly since Eric Simmer is Jewish. He seems very odd. But if you want to understand some of those complexities and paradoxes, and this is, was again, an excellent kind of profile.
他们在那里做出了不起的人物特写。所以一定要去看看。Unheard.com 斜杠 rest，U-N-H-E-R-D。现在我们回到埃及的拿破仑。欢迎来到《历史即全部》，我是多米尼克·桑德罗克和汤姆·霍兰。我们正在谈论拿破仑在埃及。汤姆，我们对这场战役本身进行了很多调侃，但显然，这真正的意义不在于军事方面……
They do wonderful profiles there. So do check it all out. Unheard.com forward slash rest U N H E R D. And now back to Napoleon in Egypt. Bienvenue au Rest de l'Historie with me Dominic Samrock and Tom Holland. We are talking about Napoleon in Egypt. Tom, we had a lot of fun with the kind of campaign, but obviously the real significance of this is not so much military
或某种外交方面。它是一种知识和文化上的，对吧？所以那些学者们，我的意思是，这就是开创埃及学的时刻。是这样吗？我想是的。所以拿破仑在晚年时，每当回想起埃及战役，他会为自己成为亚历山大的梦想破灭而感到惋惜。但他会说，从长远来看，这并不重要，因为真正的征服，那些没有留下……
or kind of diplomatic. It is kind of intellectual and cultural, isn't it? So the Savant, I mean, this is the moment that creates Egyptology. Is that right? I think it is. So Napoleon, later in life, he would look back at the Egyptian campaign and he would mourn the fact that his dream of becoming Alexander had been frustrated. But he would say, in the the long run it doesn't matter because the the real conquests the ones that uh leave behind no
遗憾的征服，是对无知的征服。天哪，我的意思是，我们都知道他其实并不是……不，我觉得他太厚颜无耻了，绝对厚颜无耻，我觉得他厚颜无耻。绝对厚颜无耻。我觉得他是真心感兴趣的。所以在旅途中，你知道，从法国到埃及的漫长旅程中，他会接待各种各样的学者，他们会一起讨论所有这些事情。对。所以基本上，在此之前，就知识领域而言，埃及很大程度上是未知领域。古埃及。
regrets are those made over ignorance oh my god i mean we all know he didn't really no i think he was shameless absolutely shameless i think he was shameless. Absolutely shameless. I think he was genuinely interested. So on the trip, you know, the long trip from France to Egypt, he would host the various savants, and they would kind of discuss all this stuff. Yeah. So basically, until this point, Egypt has been very much terra incognita intellectually. Ancient Egypt.
遗憾是出于无知，天哪，我的意思是，我们都知道他其实并非如此，不，我觉得他太厚颜无耻了，绝对厚颜无耻，我觉得他太厚颜无耻了。绝对厚颜无耻。我觉得他是真心感兴趣。所以在这次旅行中，你知道的，从法国到埃及漫长的旅程中，他会接待各路学者，然后他们会讨论所有这些事情。是的。所以基本上，直到这一刻，从知识层面上讲，埃及在很大程度上还是一片未知的土地。古埃及。
People, I mean, for example, nobody understands what hieroglyphics mean they they've tried to understand them they think there's some kind of symbolic language but they don't know what it is and obviously it's on this trip that the french find built into what the walls of a fort i think um there is a stone there is a stone yeah the key that arguably the the mo one of the most important artefacts in all world history. Yeah, so it's when Menuh, Abdullah, as he'd become by this point, and it's July 1799, so when there's a kind of threat
大家，我的意思是，比如说，没有人知道象形文字是什么意思，他们尝试去理解，觉得那是一种某种符号语言，但他们不知道那是什么，显然正是在这次远征中，法国人在一个堡垒的墙壁里发现了一块石头，有一块石头，是的，可以说这是整个世界历史上最重要的文物之一。是的，所以当梅努（Menuh），也就是后来改名为阿卜杜拉（Abdullah）的人，时间是1799年7月，当面临来自英国人和奥斯曼人等的某种威胁时，
from British and Ottomans and so on, and they're rebuilding the walls around around rosetta and they find this yeah this this kind of black stone that has three it's a trilingual announcement and one of the one of the announcements is in greek so they send it to um to cairo to this this thing called the the the institute de jeep which has been set up and it was set up in kind of august almost in 1798 so almost the moment that they get into Egypt. And that's such an enlightenment institution, isn't it? I mean, that's
他们正在重建罗塞塔周围的城墙，然后他们发现了这块黑色的石头，上面有三种——这是一个用三种语言发布的公告，其中一个公告是用希腊语写的，所以他们把它送到开罗一个叫“埃及研究所”（Institut d'Égypte）的机构，该机构成立于1798年8月左右，也就是他们进入埃及后几乎立刻成立的。这真是一个启蒙运动时期的机构，不是吗？我的意思是，这
literally what it is. It's kind of an intellectual institution. And it stood there for years. It kind of got burnt down in the Arab Spring. It did. Very sad. But and so they immediately recognised its absolute key significance and they send it back up
字面意思就是这样。它算是一个知识分子机构。它在那里屹立多年。它在阿拉伯之春期间被烧毁了。确实如此。非常遗憾。所以他们立刻认出了它绝对核心的重要意义，并把它送回
to alexandria ready to be taken back to france and then when that when all the french forces surrender in 1801 one of the terms of the surrender is that they have to hand over their loot so the british get it so that's why first the french are very weaselly about that aren't they hide a lot of their loot and the british keep saying we know you've got more what's in those crates like hidden away they know about the rosetta stone because the news of it has kind of gone around Europe like wildfire. And so the British, you know, they definitely want it. So that's why it's ended up in the British Museum
亚历山大港，准备带回法国。然后，当所有法国军队在1801年投降时，投降的条件之一就是他们必须交出战利品，于是英国人得到了它。这就是为什么起初法国人在这件事上非常狡猾，对吧？他们藏起了很多战利品，而英国人一直在说：“我们知道你们还有更多，那些板条箱里藏着什么？”他们知道罗塞塔石碑，因为它的消息像野火一样传遍了整个欧洲。所以英国人，你知道，他们绝对想要它。这就是为什么它最终留在了大英博物馆
and not the Louvre. But what the French do have is that they have sent this expedition up the Nile to kind of chase the Mamluks and the various savants have gone. And there's this incredible description of them arriving at Thebes. So Luxor, Valley of the Kings, you know, this great monumental capital where bits of it are kind of still sticking out above the sand. And it's sufficiently impressive that when the French army arrived there, apparently they all spontaneously burst into applause at the site.
而不是卢浮宫。但法国人确实做的一件事是，他们派了一支远征队沿尼罗河溯流而上，去追击马木鲁克和各路学者。这里对他们抵达底比斯（Thebes）有段不可思议的描述：卢克索、帝王谷，你知道，这个宏伟的纪念碑式都城，其中一部分依然挺立在沙子上面。那里的景象相当震撼，以至于当法国军队抵达那里时，据说他们在遗址前情不自禁地集体鼓掌。
I thought you were going to say they burst into tears. That would have been much more burst into tears that would have been much more french baby i'm sure some of them did i'm sure some of them did um and then they come back so that's in january when when of course the um the climate in luxor is is gorgeous but they come back in the summer and reconnoiter the valley of the king so they're the first europeans and it's so hot that two of them die of heat stroke wow but imagine what it has to be like tom i mean now when you're a child you know all children do ancient egypt at school and they're so conscious of of them of mummies of the tombs of the you know the pyramids but imagine what that must have been like to have been the first people you know to be i mean they're
我还以为你会说他们放声大哭呢。那会更加——放声大哭，那会更加法兰西风格，宝贝，我相信他们当中有些人确实哭了，我相信有些人确实哭了，呃然后他们回来了，那是在一月份，当然卢克索的气候那时美极了，但他们在夏天又回来侦察帝王谷，所以他们是第一批欧洲人，天气太热了，其中两人中暑身亡。哇，不过汤姆，想象一下当时的情景会是怎样——我的意思是，现在当你还是个孩子的时候，你知道所有孩子在学校都会学古埃及，他们对木乃伊、陵墓、金字塔有着强烈的意识，但想象一下，成为第一批人——你知道，成为——我的意思是，他们
not the first europeans of course they're nothing it. But they arrive and many of them do not know what to expect, do they? I mean, the Savant will have a sense that there's something there. But the ordinary soldiers, I mean, it must just be, if you're coming from, you know, the foothills of the Pyrenees or something or the, you know, the wine-growing villages of Burgundy, I mean, this just must be mind-blowing to see. And I think it is for the Savant as well, because they're finding stuff that that no european has seen before and um recording it
当然不是第一批欧洲人，根本不是。但他们抵达时，许多人并不知道会发生什么，对吧？我的意思是，学者们会有一种“那里有些东西”的感觉。但普通士兵，我的意思是，如果你来自比利牛斯山的的山麓或者是勃艮第的葡萄酒产区，看到这个绝对会大开眼界。我想对学者们来说也是如此，因为他们发现了前所未见的欧洲人从未见过的事物，并将其记录下来，
tracing it all down um but that's what they do isn't it there's amazing books that they produce the um what's it called the description de l'egypte 1821 four volumes i think it's one now one if you can get a copy it's one of the most valuable books on the market, on the Canadian aquarium market. It's stunning. And it's a kind of Wikipedia of Egypt. So it's not just the antiquities. It's, you know, how people dress, musical instruments they play. And that's a very enlightening thing, isn't it?
一一追踪记录，但这就是他们所做的，不是吗？他们出版了令人惊叹的书籍，那个叫什么来着，《埃及记述》（Description de l'Égypte），1821年，四卷本，我想现在如果你能弄到一套，它可是市场上最有价值的书籍之一，在古董书市场上。它太惊艳了。它就像一本埃及的百科全书。所以不仅有文物，还有人们的穿着、演奏的乐器。这是一件非常具有启蒙意义的事，对吧？
It is. Napoleon has basically taken people and said you know compile an encyclopedia of egypt i suppose edward saeed would say it's a very colonialist project as well it's well it's about we can maybe come to him in a little yeah um he would of course um but one of the other one of the i mean one of the reasons why the um the discovery of the uh of the antiquities is has has the impact it does, is that it's not just Europeans who don't really know anything about it. The Egyptians don't either.
确实如此。拿破仑基本上带上了学者，对他们说，你知道，编纂一部埃及的百科全书。我想爱德华·萨义德（Edward Said）会说这也是一个非常殖民主义的项目，好吧，这关乎——我们等下或许可以谈到他，嗯，他当然会这么认为——但其中的一个原因，我的意思是，古物发现之所以会产生如此大的影响，是因为不仅是欧洲人对此一无所知，埃及人也同样如此。
The Egyptians, you know, there was a stage where the Egyptians were interested in the pharaonic monuments, but that stage is long gone. And basically, they don't understand why anyone would be as interested in these antiquities as the French seem to be. And one of the measures of that is that, you know, the Great Pyramid, the kind of primal symbol of pharaonic civilization,
埃及人，你知道，曾有一段时间埃及人对法老时期的古迹感兴趣，但那个时期早已过去。基本上，他们不明白为什么会有人像法国人那样对这些古物感兴趣。其中一个体现就是，你知道，大金字塔——法老文明的最初象征，
that the passageways that lead into it have become cluttered and impassable. And so Napoleon orders that in the first summer that he's in Egypt to be cleared and he then he goes into the king's chamber where the body of Cheops was placed and he orders everybody else out and he sits there communing with his destiny and he self-consciously models that on Alexander going to the oracle at Siwa and he self-consciously models that on alexander going to the oracle at siwa and he never revealed what he thought or what what you know was said what was said by the by the mummy yeah yeah but again a kind of just such a kind of fabulously histrionic scene um so so there's all that and and and as we said the the british kind of claim
通往其中的通道已经变得杂乱无章、无法通行。于是拿破仑下令在他身处埃及的第一个夏天将其清理干净，然后他走进了胡夫（Cheops）的遗体曾被安置的国王墓室，命令其他人全部出去，他独自坐在那里与自己的命运对话，他下意识地模仿亚历山大前往锡瓦（Siwa）神谕所的行为，他下意识地模仿亚历山大前往锡瓦神谕所的行为，但他从未透露过自己的想法，或者说，你知道，木乃伊说了什么，说了什么，是的，是的，但依然是这样一个极其戏剧化的场景，所以，所有这一切，正如我们所说，英国人宣称
the bragging rights politically i mean they establish a political protectorate over egypt that in the long run uh you know lasts right the way up to suez really i guess um but the french established this this sense that they are the people who have brought ancient egypt back to life um and i guess that there are two things that really embed that one of them as you as you said is the description of egypt which is commissioned by napoleon just as he's leaving egypt um and all these kind of various volumes come out and and they're still being produced even after napoleon has been defeated and and died but the other thing is that um there's a guy called joseph fouillet who's a mathematician and he becomes the first president of the institute in cairo and he gets back with he goes with napoleon on the skedaddle back to france and he settles in grenoble and he has all
拥有政治上的吹嘘资本，我的意思是，他们在埃及建立了一个政治保护国，从长远来看，你知道，一直持续到苏伊士运河事件，我想，嗯，但法国人确立了一种感觉，即他们是让古埃及复活的人，我想有两件事真正巩固了这一点，其中一件正如你所说，是拿破仑在离开埃及前委托编写的《埃及记述》，各种卷册相继问世，甚至在拿破仑被击败并去世后仍在继续出版，但另一件事是，嗯，有一个叫约瑟夫·傅里叶（Joseph Fourier）的数学家，他成为了开罗研究所的第一任所长，他跟着拿破仑仓皇撤退回到法国，并在格勒诺布尔（Grenoble）定居，他的身边环绕着各种
kinds of antiquities around him and growing up in grenooble is a small boy called Jean-Francois Champollion. Now, he's a huge figure, isn't he, in the understanding of Egypt? Because isn't it not him? Is he not the person who discovers how the Rosetta Stone works? Is that right? So he cracks the hieroglyphs. Yes. So he uses the texts from the Rosetta Stone basically to crack the hieroglyphs. Yes. So he uses the texts from the Rosetta Stone basically to crack the hieroglyphs.
古物，而在格勒诺布尔长大的一个小男孩名叫让-弗朗索瓦·商博良（Jean-Francois Champollion）。现在，他在理解埃及方面是一个巨人的存在，对吧？因为难道不是他吗？难道不是他发现了罗塞塔石碑的工作原理吗？是这样吗？所以他破解了象形文字。是的。所以他基本上利用罗塞塔石碑上的文本破解了象形文字。所以他基本上利用罗塞塔石碑上的文本破解了象形文字。
And this is what then opens up the understanding of Egypt. And he goes back to Egypt and he goes down the Nile. And he's probably the first person who can read the hieroglyphs since antiquity. Well, I mean, he is. I i mean it's kind of an amazing thought but also what's what's kind of um tantalizing is that he's he's probably also the last person to see egypt as perhaps um someone in late antiquity or the early middle ages would have seen it because what's going on is that um egypt's been taken over by this guy this albanian adventurer called mehmet ali who is muhammad ali who is he's an amazing character isn't he i mean he's he he absolutely is and he is very he has no interest in antiquities at all which is why he's a modernizer he's perfectly happy for the british and the french to kind of
这正是开启对埃及理解的关键。他回到了埃及并沿尼罗河而下。他可能是自古代以来第一个能阅读象形文字的人。好吧，我的意思是，他的确是。我的意思是，这真是一个惊人的想法，但也有些……令人神往的是，他可能也是最后一位以古代晚期或中世纪早期之人的视角来看待埃及的人，因为当时发生的事情是，埃及被一个名叫穆罕默德·阿里（Mehmet Ali/Muhammad Ali）的阿尔巴尼亚冒险家占领了，他是穆罕默德·阿里，他是一个了不起的人物，不是吗？我的意思是，他绝对是，而且他
engage in competitive antiquity rustling so that's how how, you know, the statue of Ozymandias in the British Museum, loads of antiquities in the Louvre, that's how they get there. And those that don't get taken by European plunderers kind of just get smashed, used as, you know, for lime kilns or whatever. So Lodes, so Champollion is the first to read hieroglyphs and he's possibly the last to see the antiquities
对古物毫无兴趣，这就是为什么他是一个现代化主义者，他非常乐见英国人和法国人参与竞争性的掠夺古物活动，这就是为什么大英博物馆里的奥济曼迪亚斯（Ozymandias）雕像、卢浮宫里的众多古物能够到达那里。而那些没有被欧洲掠夺者带走的古物，则被砸碎，用作石灰窑或其他用途。因此，商博良是第一个阅读象形文字的人，而他很可能是最后一个看到那些古物的人，
as they had been for centuries and centuries and centuries before egypt really kind of explodes into tomorrow and the kind of irony tom is that even as this stuff is being either taken away or destroyed in egypt there's this kind of egyptomania all over the kind of western world so it's just a few decades later you get the construction of say the was Monument to George Washington which is done as an Egyptian obelisk, something that probably wouldn't have been done that way 50 or 100 years ago
就像它们在埃及真正爆发进入现代之前的几个世纪里一直保持的那样。而汤姆，这里的讽刺之处在于，正当这些东西在埃及被带走或摧毁时，整个西方世界却掀起了一股“埃及狂热”（Egyptomania），仅仅几十年后，人们就开始建造比如献给乔治·华盛顿的纪念碑，它被设计成一个埃及方尖碑，这在50或100年前可能不会以这种方式建造，
but because of the aftermath of Napoleon's invasion there is this absolute kind of mad fascination with all things Egyptian. And the obelisks being brought from Egypt, say Cleopatra's Needle to London, the one that was taken to New York,, every thrusting capital of a Western power has to have an obelisk.
但由于拿破仑入侵的余波，人们对所有与埃及相关的事物产生了绝对疯狂的迷恋。方尖碑被从埃及运走，比如伦敦的克利奥帕特拉针柱（Cleopatra's Needle），运往纽约的那座，西方强国的每一个蓬勃发展的首都都必须拥有一座方尖碑。
And you need to be Freud to work out maybe what's going on there. But that's also kind of a Roman thing, isn't it? Because after Octavian had defeated Cleopatra, the Romans started putting out obelisks to remind themselves of how they'd captured Egypt. And so there's a sort of weird kind of classicism in that as well isn't there yeah so the sense that um the greeks and the romans had ruled egypt uh and now the western powers
你得是弗洛伊德才能弄明白那里到底发生了什么。但这也算是一种罗马风格，对吧？因为在屋大维击败克利奥帕特拉之后，罗马人开始竖起方尖碑，来提醒自己他们是如何征服埃及的。所以其中也有一种奇怪的古典主义，不是吗？是的，所以这种感觉——希腊人和罗马人曾统治过埃及，而现在西方列强
should should equally have a stake is is definitely a part of what's going on but conversely um just as people in um in in europe are getting obsessed by Egypt, the Egyptians are very, very conscious of basically just how technologically advanced the French had been relative to, say, the Mamluks. And one of the things that Muhammad Ali does is, as part of his process of of modernization is to send Egyptian Savant to Paris and there's this one guy Rifa al-Tatawi who who um wrote a brilliant account of his trip to Paris um and again there's this sense of um you know as as with napoleon going to egypt the sense that he's struggling to get a handle on a very different way of seeing the world so likewise with al-tatawi you he so he describes france as a land of infidelity and obstinacy um one of their bad customs is their claim that the intellect of their philosophers and physicists is greater and more perceptive than that of prophets um and there's there's uh there's there's a french
也同样应该分一杯羹——绝对是其中一部分。但相反，就在欧洲人对埃及痴迷不已的同时，埃及人也非常、非常清楚地意识到，相比于马木鲁克等人，法国人的技术是多么先进。穆罕默德·阿里所做的事情之一，作为其现代化进程的一部分，就是派遣埃及学者去巴黎，其中有一个叫里法·托塔维（Rifa'a al-Tahtawi）的人，他写了一篇关于其巴黎之行的精彩游记，同样，这种感觉——就像拿破仑前往埃及一样，他努力去理解一种截然不同的世界观，对于托塔维来说也是如此，他将法国描述为一片不信神和固执的土地，
observer of these egyptians who've come to paris to study and he's he says of them that um the only things that they learned to do in paris was to speak passable, to drink wine and to laugh at Mohammed. Really? So this is very kind of, is it the guy Kutub who went to America in the 1950s? Is that right? There's a kind of weird echo of that, isn't there? Well, Tatawi is more enthusiastic. He comes back to Egypt and he's he founds a kind of a European language centre. Right. So that people can learn languages and kind of translate treatises
他们糟糕的习俗之一是声称他们的哲学家和物理学家的智慧比先知们更伟大、更有洞察力；并且有一个法国观察员对这些来到巴黎学习的埃及人评价说，他们在巴黎唯一学会做的事情就是说得一口像样的法语、喝葡萄酒以及嘲笑穆罕默德。真的吗？这非常类似于，是那个在20世纪50年代去过美国的库特布（Sayyid Qutb）吗？是这样吗？这其中有一种奇怪的呼应，不是吗？嗯，托塔维更加热情。他回到埃及后，创立了一个欧洲语言中心，
and industrialise and improve agriculture and all that kind of stuff. So that's going on. But essentially it generates tensions within the traditional model of Islamic culture that are enduring to the present day. Because the thing is that up until Napoleon lands at Alexandria, basically nobody in the Muslim world had bothered with what the infidels were doing. And they just had no interest in them, couldn't care. And it's assumed that Islam is able to structure everything. And essentially, the shock of realising that that is not the case.
好让人们学习语言、翻译论文、实现工业化、改进农业以及诸如此类的事情。所以这些都在发生。但本质上，它在伊斯兰传统的文化模式内部产生了持续到今天的紧张关系。因为问题在于，直到拿破仑登陆亚历山大港之前，穆斯林世界的基本上没有人去理会异教徒在做什么。他们对他们毫无兴趣，根本不在乎。人们默认伊斯兰教能够构建一切。而本质上，当意识到事实并非如此时，那种冲击是巨大的。
And what do you how do you do that? Do you try and integrate Islam with the kind of the trends that Napoleon and then the other European powers embody? Do you reject them completely? I mean, what do you do? These are tensions that are enduring throughout the Islamic world throughout the 19th and 20th century, into the 21st century. And of course, as so, so there's one of the comments of Tataoui when he goes to Paris, he says there's not a single Muslim settled in Paris. I mean, that is clearly no longer the case. And so those those arguments and those tensions have to be resolved by Muslims who are now living in France. But they also can see that what's going on with the presidential election moment in France. These are issues that are now dominating
你该怎么办？你如何应对？你是否试图将伊斯兰教与拿破仑及其他西方列强所体现的趋势相融合？你是否完全拒绝它们？我的意思是，你该怎么做？这些紧张关系贯穿了整个19世纪、20世纪一直延续到21世纪的整个伊斯兰世界。当然，正如托塔维去巴黎时的一条评论所说，巴黎没有一个穆斯林定居者。我的意思是，这显然已经不再是事实了。因此，那些争论和紧张关系必须由现在生活在法国的穆斯林来解决。但他们也能看到，法国当前的总统选举时刻正在发生什么。这些问题现在也主导着
mainstream French discourse as well. And as you say, it's a particular issue for France, isn't it? Because France has that kind of sense that Napoleon himself had of the kind of secular, rational, enlightened, of Frenchness being bound up with secularism, with liberalism, which they, as you say, they think of that as something outside religion. But I have a terrible feeling, knowing you, that you will say that is actually a product of their Christian heritage. Am I right? Yeah, I'm absolutely going to say that. I'm absolutely going to say that because it's
法国主流话语。正如你所说，这对法国来说是一个特殊的问题，对吧？因为法国有一种拿破仑本人所具有的世俗、理性、开朗的法兰西性与世俗主义、自由主义交织在一起的感觉，正如你所说，他们认为这是宗教之外的东西。但我有一种可怕的预感，了解你的话，你会说这其实是他们基督教传统的产物。我说的对吗？是的，我绝对会这么说。我绝对会这么说，因为这
clearly true, because the French are exporting, you know, deeply Christian assumptions about the possibility of church and state being separate entities. I mean, you know, there's no equivalent to the phrase church and state in your fluent Arabic. Of course not. So what about this? What about this Edward Said business? this uh edward saeed business so we should definitely so for those people who don't know edward saeed is this sort of palestinian intellectual 20th century um writing sort of 1970s 1980s here is a book called orientalism that was massively influential but i think historians a lot of historians have said is utter utter utter utter utter bunkum um do you think it's utter bunkum?
显然是真的，因为法国人正在输出关于教会与国家作为独立实体的可能性的深刻基督教假设。我的意思是，在你的流利阿拉伯语中，没有与“教会与国家”（church and state）这个短语等同的表达。当然没有。那么这个呢？关于爱德华·萨义德的这些事呢？这个由爱德华·萨义德引发的事，所以我们绝对应该——对于那些不知道的人来说，爱德华·萨义德是20世纪的巴勒斯坦知识分子，主要在20世纪70年代、80年代写作，写了一本名为《东方主义》（Orientalism）的书，产生了巨大的影响，但我认为许多历史学家说这是彻头彻尾的无稽之谈，你觉得这是无稽之谈吗？
Well, I don't think you can make so many... I mean, we all make mistakes, but I mean, to make... I don't think it's utter bunkum. I think when you've made so many mistakes... I think the controlling idea that for the Europeans in the 19th century, of whom Napoleon's Savants are the kind of archetype, the attempt to understand the countries that they were occupying was itself a part of colonial control. I mean, that seems to me indisputably true. But that's also just common sense.
嗯，我不认为你可以做出这么多——我的意思是，我们都会犯错，但我的意思是，做出——我不认为这是无稽之谈。我认为那个核心观点是：对于19世纪的欧洲人来说，拿破仑的学者们就是这种观点的原型，他们试图理解他们正在占领的国家的企图本身就是殖民控制的一部分。我的意思是，在我看来这无疑是真实的。但这也就是常识。
I mean, that's just blindingly obvious. But to elaborate that into this grand theory. I wouldn't say that because I would also say that it's indicative of a curiosity that I think is rather admirable. You know, so it takes time for the Egyptians to become interested in ancient Egypt. You know, by the time the Tutankhamen is discovered, they're very interested in it. They're not going to let it all go off to London or whatever. But in the early decades of the 19th century, they're not interested in it at all. And it's the Europeans who are interested in it. And I feel grateful to the Savants that they, you know, they went and they, you know,
我的意思是，这显而易见。但要把这一点详细阐述为一个宏大的理论。我不会这么说，因为我也会说这表明了一种我認為相当令人钦佩的好奇心。你知道，埃及人花了一段时间才对古埃及产生兴趣。你知道，当图坦卡蒙被发现时，他们非常感兴趣。他们不会让这一切都被带到伦敦或其他地方。但在19世纪的最初几十年里，他们对此毫无兴趣。是欧洲人在对此感兴趣。我心怀感激地认为，那些学者们，他们去了，而且，
in many cases, they made illustrations, made it studies of monuments that no longer exist because they were demolished by the modernizing program of of memetalli yeah i don't i mean um tom i don't think anyone would surely well i mean you'd have to be very very impassioned i think um to disagree with that i mean obviously their curiosity is is one of the things that allowed these things to be preserved and that created created Egyptology and they created a lot of these things. But also to see people, especially in sort of the sort of debased form of Edward Said's thesis, which is to see almost all Western intellectual engagement of the East as a product of colonialism and only about power and only about control and all this. I think that is, I mean, I think Robert Irwin wrote a brilliant book about Orientalism that was a complete riposte to say. They kind of sewed his, you know,
在许多情况下，他们制作了插图，对那些因穆罕默德·阿里的现代化计划而被拆除的古迹进行了研究。我不认为——汤姆，我不认为会有人——好吧，我的意思是，你得非常、非常充满激情，我想，才会去反驳这一点。显然，他们的好奇心正是让这些事物得以保存、并创造了埃及学以及许多此类事物的原因之一。但同时，把人们——尤其是以爱德华·萨义德论文那种贬低的形式，将西方对东方的几乎所有知识介入都视为殖民主义的产物，完全只关乎权力和控制——我认为，罗伯特·欧文（Robert Irwin）写了一本关于东方主义的精彩著作，那是对萨义德的彻底反驳。他们某种程度上把他的，你知道的，
just levelled his cities to the ground and said, a lot of these people are actually themselves anti-imperialist, that they weren't necessarily great advocates of empire and all this kind of thing. And then actually- But again, it's complicated, isn't it? Because Napoleon is saying, we're coming here to free you um we're coming here because we're against empires we're against the british empire we're against the ottoman empire but
将他的观点夷为平地，并指出其中许多人实际上本身就是反帝国主义者，他们不一定是帝国的大力拥护者等等诸如此类。然后实际上——但话说回来，情况很复杂，对吧？因为拿破仑在说，我们来这里是为了解放你们，我们来这里是因为我们反对帝国，我们反对大英帝国，我们反对奥斯曼帝国，但是
i think it's more complicated than that i mean i think i think i think there's a lot of of um i think napoleon is in a way that's perhaps typical of quite a lot of European figures in the early 19th century, simultaneously idealistic and deeply cynical. And the two seem kind of able to coexist in a way that perhaps we in the 21st century find difficult to understand. Maybe. I mean, Napoleon, if you put him alongside the people he worshipped, Caesar, Alexander and so on, I think he actually makes complete sense, doesn't he? That blend of political opportunism and sort of genuine self-belief, but also a belief in his moral mission. I mean, those things quite happily coexist. But yes, but I think that we in the 21st century for reflecting kind of the way that the culture wars rumble,
我认为事情比这更复杂。我的意思是，我认为拿破仑的方式可能具有19世纪初许多欧洲人物的典型特征，既理想主义又极其愤世嫉俗。这两者似乎能够共存，而这或许是我们身处21世纪的人难以理解的。也许吧。我的意思是，如果把拿破仑与他崇拜的人（恺撒、亚历山大等）放在一起，我认为他其实完全说得通，对吧？那种政治机会主义与真正的自信的融合，以及对自身道德使命的信念。我的意思是，这些东西可以非常和谐地共存。但是，是的，但我认为我们身处21世纪，反映了文化战争的喧嚣，
we have a much more binary sense. Yeah, we do. That you're either an anti-imperialist or you're a colonialist. Yeah, right. In fact, you know, both of those are equally European. I mean, they're equally Western. So it's not like, you know, and you see them intermixed in the figure of Napoleon.
我们有一种更为二元的看法。是的，确实如此。即你要么是反帝国主义者，要么是殖民主义者。是的，没错。事实上，你知道，这两者同样都是欧洲的产物。我的意思是，它们同样属于西方。所以并不是说，你知道的，你会在拿破仑身上看到它们交织在一起。
You see them intermixed in the figure of Napoleon. You see them intermixed in this whole extraordinary expedition. And I think that it is, you know, one of the absolutely kind of foundational episodes in modern history, modern global history. Because actually, when you think about European history, particularly before Napoleon, I mean, certainly in the sort of 17th, 18th century, the Ottoman Empire, the world of the Middle East,
你会看到它们在拿破仑身上交织在一起。你会看到它们交织在这一整场非凡的远征中。我认为这绝对是现代历史、现代全球历史中最基础的事件之一。因为事实上，当你回想欧洲历史，尤其是拿破仑之前，我的意思是，当然在17、18世纪，奥斯曼帝国，中东的世界，
the engagement with Islam, they've slightly been pushed to the side, haven't they? I know there's the Siege of Jena and all that kind of stuff. But for example, in Britain and in France, they're no longer really thinking about Christendom versus Islam in the 18th century, are they? And then after the invasion, that will be very different. Yes. the 18th century are they and then after the invasion that will be very different yes and i mean you i well you've got you've kind of got this awakening of interest in each so as early
与伊斯兰教的关系，它们稍微被靠边了，不是吗？我知道有耶拿战役以及诸如此类的东西。但例如，在英国和法国，在18世纪，他们实际上已经不再考虑基督教世界与伊斯兰教的对抗了，对吧？然后入侵之后，情况就会大不相同了。是的。在18世纪是这样的，对吧？然后入侵之后，情况就会大不相同了。是的。我的意思是，你……嗯，你有一种对彼此兴趣的觉醒，早在
as the 17th century 1780 something leibniz the the philosopher and and mathematician is suggesting to louis the 14th that the french go and invade egypt um and he's basically doing that to try and stop louis the 14th from invading germany but but there's a kind of sense that that egypt is of interest um and then you've got you've got uh there's this guy the comp de volney who's going to egypt drawing up that kind of sober report but then is is he he does a kind of very romantic uh portrayal of egypt as a land of ruins and timelessness and things. So that's also kind of feeding into it. And I think that there is, and I guess that Edward Said maybe has a point here, that there's a sense perhaps in which lots of people in Europe are more interested in a kind of fantasy of ancient Egypt than they are in the reality of...
17世纪，1780年代左右，哲学家兼数学家莱布尼茨向路易十四建议法国去侵略埃及，嗯，他基本上这么做是为了试图阻止路易十四侵略德国，但是，人们有一种感觉，即埃及是令人感兴趣的，然后你还有……有这么一个人，孔德·德·沃尔尼，他去埃及撰写了那种严肃的报告，但随后他……他对埃及进行了非常浪漫的描绘，将其描绘成一个废墟和永恒之地的国度，诸如此类。所以这也算是一种助推。而且我认为，我想爱德华·萨义德在这里也许有他的道理，那就是在某种程度上，欧洲的许多人可能对古代埃及的某种幻想更感兴趣，而不是对它的现实感兴趣……
Yeah, but again, that's true of everything, right? I think that is true. We're always interested in the fantasy of something rather than reality of it. I mean, that's just the way the human imagination works. Anyway, I think we've probably... Well, we haven't quite done this to death. I mean, there's tons more to say about it,
是的，但话又说回来，对所有事情都是如此，对吧？我认为确实如此。我们总是对事物的某种幻想更感兴趣，而不是对它的现实本身。我的意思是，这正是人类想象力运作的方式。无论如何，我想我们大概……嗯，我们还没有把这个话题彻底聊完。我的意思是，还有海量的话题可以聊，
but we should probably wrap this up. Well, there's certainly tons more to say about Napoleon, isn't it? And this is the first episode we've done on Napoleon. It is. A real gap. And I have to say that kind of getting back to this whole theme just reminds me what an amazing figure he is. And Nelson as well, and lots to come.
但我们大概应该结束了。嗯，关于拿破仑确实还有海量的话题可聊，不是吗？这是我们做的第一期关于拿破仑的节目。确实是的。这是一个真正的空白。我必须说，回到这个主题让我想起他是多么了不起的人物。还有纳尔逊也是，精彩内容还在后头。
Yeah, we've got to do Nelson, Tom. We will see you soon. A bientot. Bye-bye. Au revoir. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
是的，我们必须做一期关于纳尔逊的节目，汤姆。我们很快再见。再见。拜拜。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁内容、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。